(instrumental music)
- [Narrator] Welcome to Iowa,
where wind turbines rule the land.
And in the town of Esthervile,
there is a wind program dishing out
some of the best wind
technicians in the country.
- I'm Joel Caulfield,
and I'm here with my dad, Jim Caulfield.
- We here are students at
Iowa Lakes Community College,
and we're studying to be
wind turbine technicians.
(instrumental music)
(light music)
- [Narrator] This is Iowa
Lakes Community College-
a school that offers an
intensive two-year program
in applied science and
wind turbine technology.
Jim and his son, Joel,
are students who entered
the program together.
- A wind technician is
somebody who would actually
work on the wind turbine to make sure
that it is being serviced properly
and, if it breaks down,
actually be able to repair it.
- We just basically take a variations
of different electrical theory classes,
all the way up to advanced level stuff
of actually wiring up circuits
and advanced programming of computers.
- Wind turbine is actually
big pieces of equipment
that carry a lot of risk, and
that's why they are ingraining
in us everything we need to know,
so that when we're up there we know how
to handle every situation
we can deal with.
- When you're going out to a turbine
for the first time, you're
very anxious and nervous
because you're going at a height
that you're never been to before.
I mean there's a lot of fall
potential that could happen.
- To elaborate on what Joel's saying,
it's serious stuff that you
don't take lightly at all.
- When you get to the top,
you just start to get more
of an excitement over fear and exhaustion
because now you're up
there in the cell itself,
so it's actually kind of cool to see
a working turbine in first action.
- [Narrator] For Jim and
Joel, going back to school
was a no-brainer.
Jim left the trucking
industry after 26 years
to follow his passion in renewable energy,
and his son, Joel, wanted
to travel the world
and work with this hands, so
enrolling in the wind program
at the same time, while unconventional,
ended up working out perfectly.
- We can bounce off each other for ideas
and stuff like that, help
each other with like homework,
so it kind of gave us an
opportunity to grow better.
- There's a lot of things
that I'm still scratchin'
my head on, and, you know, he'll
just come by, and he's like
well, you gotta do this, you gotta,
how the heck do you know that?
How the heck you know,
but he does, he gets it.
It's actually a great feeling knowing that
I have a chance to, you know,
pursue a career in something
that I've been very passionate about.
There are other people doing this,
and it's worth it for anybody to go ahead
and make that next leap.
(light music)